uh we're going to go back to the speech
in just a minute let's get some quick
snap reaction first from Pete hegseth
who's been watching along with us Pete
he went through every issue of success
every issue of failure as it relates to
the bite Administration uh how this
country has changed so dramatically in
the last two years
um he uh I have a I just got an early
copy of the of the text just now and I'm
looking at it we'll go back uh in a
minute when he has a pretty important
close but uh your thoughts so far
a cold plant every week well Sean
nothing like the original uh there he
went back to the themes that put him in
the White House from fair trade to
borders to ending nonsense Foreign Wars
to saying we the people have been
ignored by Washington D.C it's a
forward-looking speech that recognizing
the disaster of the last two years he
said as president I delivered for you
where other presidents have not that
this looks like Trump in in as good a
form as you've ever seen him sticking to
the issues that matter to his voters
making the case to Republican primary
voters that he's the guy to continue to
be the standard Bearer as the original
that remade the party there will be
others many of which leverage their
association with Trump to get where they
are who will try to be like Trump
there's only one original who got to the
White House and fought and I think if he
stays on message the way he did tonight
he's got a formidable case to make to a
Republican an electric Governor Huckabee
we will lift up the working men and
women we will restore the fabric of this
great nation we declare it does not have
to be this way America's comeback starts
right now I kept my promises uh we are
now a nation in Decline and Americans
are suffering pain hardship anxiety
Despair and you know America has now
become mocked derided and brought to its
knees could you have imagined all this
happening in two short years because I
frankly couldn't
Sean the construct of the speech is
Pitch Perfect if he keeps on like this
tonight he is unbeatable in 2024. nobody
can touch him not a republican not a
Democrat he stayed on message one of the
key things he said this is not my
campaign this is our campaign he has
made it about the American people he's
reminded them that the reason they voted
for him
once in most of us twice was because he
was fighting for us and he made the
comment this is not about critics and
complainers he's looking forward I'm
telling you this was an absolutely
brilliant speech the best I've heard him
give in a long time and he stays on this
message I agree with Pete he stays and
keeps it between the ditches and this
Focus he's unbeatable
you know I I think you might be able to
make the case Pete hegseth you know all
of his policies and and he went through
a list of all of them and he talked
about inflation non-existent he talked
about secure borders he talked about his
defeat of the caliphate he talked about
energy Independence he talked about how
peace through strength worked uh and and
how he kept his promises as I said you
know then he compared it to higher gas
prices record high inflation uh
surrendering energy Independence our
Southern borders he called it an
invasion and along with it Fentanyl and
opioids uh and what a failure it's been
the failure in Afghanistan the failure
in Ukraine
um all of these things I know people
might you know have had many people over
the years Pete say you know the policies
are perfect you know does he have to
fight that much and you know and and
send out these tweets and all I'm sure
you've gotten the same questions too and
I'm like thinking well if you were lied
about for three years about Russia you
might be a little defensive and a little
combative also
well Sean he had to fight to get just on
the debate stage on the Republican side
to be the nominee it was always a fight
and then from there he was lied about so
he's had to be a fighter he is the
preeminent Fighter for freedom for
America first of our generation
absolutely no doubt about it then once
he got there to your point Sean he
delivered on every prerogative any
Conservative Republican or America first
uh supporter would have wanted he said
he would do it and then he did it from
the Supreme Court to the Isis caliphate
to energy dominance to taxes across the
board he was committed to it he took the
slings and arrows they're even coming
out tonight for media outlets right now
the headlines are pre-written about who
Donald Trump is he's taken those arrows
on behalf of everyone else and delivered
if he reminds voters of that stays
disciplined on those tops it makes it
about us about we the people about their
their come they're coming after you I'm
just standing in the way those lines
that he's made iconic people will be
reminded despite the noise of how good
their life was because of the policies
of Donald Trump and pull the lever for
him it's not going to be easy to beat
this guy I agree with Governor Huckabee
he's at the top of his game having had
the results making the case and you can
be riding away or have other arguments
the original is a is a flavor in and of
itself and you're seeing that tonight
from Donald Trump
let me bring in uh Congressman Jim
Jordan and Monica Crowley Jim you've
always been a champion a big supporter
of Donald Trump when you look at this
Donald Trump tonight a very serious
very powerful speech this is this is
Donald Trump and it's game time for him
yeah you're exactly I think Pete and the
governor had it exactly right this is
our campaign that is that is the key
line Sean Sean I think of the great
coaches the great coaches are the ones
where their athletes know that that
coach puts their athletes interests
first that is exactly what what
president Trump has done for the
American people when you've been to
these rallies these huge rallies and
president Trump has a great line he says
the left comes after me because I'm
fighting for you his audience knows that
his supporters know that there is a bond
there is a relationship that forms and
so that very first line which is
America's comeback starts today that is
what this is about and that is why so
many people are attracted to this guy
and how he fights for this country
because they know he puts their
interests first their family's interests
first and America's interest first and
that is what matters more than anything
especially now with what we've seen from
Joe Biden in the left
and by the way what an appropriate day
congratulations Jim Jordan you are now
officially going to be investigating a
lot of uh things that have gone under
the radar for the last number of years
looking time for all of that Monica
Crowley
let's get your thoughts before we go
back to the president
the president the Republicans secured
the majority in the House of
Representatives so look president Trump
has taken a severe pounding over the
last seven years I've never seen
anything like it it is a miracle that
the man is still standing and he's
certainly taken a pounding over the last
week or so after the midterms but this
man has always put the Forgotten man and
woman first when he said that line
tonight about this is not my campaign
this is our campaign altogether it
reminded me back in 2016 when Mrs
Clinton had a slogan that said I'm with
her and Trump turned around and said I'm
with you
and that kind of fighting spirit for the
American people and he's it's not just a
campaign promise anymore he has a long
track record of being president actually
delivering for the Forgotten man and
woman that's the kind of thing he is
resurrecting tonight he has turned the
page on 2020. this was a forward-looking
address based on policy and principle
and hope for delivering America out of
this historic catastrophe known as the
Biden presidency let's get some quick
commentary from uh our friend Joe Concha
and Leo 2.0 Terrell Leo I don't think
there's a bigger fan in the country of
Donald Trump than you uh I'm watching
this president at this hour and I'm
seeing uh a guy that is that looks like
he is dead on Focus that this is real
they took him back hey you know Sean on
your program two years ago I came out on
your program and told you my support for
president Trump first time I ever voted
for a republican why you could see it
tonight he cares he cares about the
American people and the American people
resonate towards Trump this is what he
has that the other candidates will never
obtain the ability to draw in the crowd
because they trust him and he has a
record to run on this is a guy who is
very comfortable in front of the
American people because they trust him
and I'll tell you right now I'm more
determined than ever before on your
program two years ago more now I'm a big
Trump supporter because he cares about
America as a civil rights attorney I
care and that's why I'm supporting Trump
again
you know one thing that I would argue
Joe Concha the president has made his
case about issues involving elections
and fraud Etc no talk of that tonight he
has he has seemed to have evolved into
he would like to see states of all paper
ballots like Canada and like France and
like Great Britain and you have partisan
observers watch the vote count and watch
uh the voting and uh you know I think
that is uh probably a big step in many
people's minds that they said okay we've
heard that point now it's about the
future because elections are about the
future
that's correct that the tone was the
right one here Sean no question it felt
more like a State of the Union Address
and less like a rally speech Donald
Trump tonight largely stuck to the
issues all the crises that are ailing
this country and it was disciplined He
was largely positive in terms of his
vision sure he took a couple shots at
Joe Biden but it was benign stuff in in
Trump terms and he reminded those
watching of his various accomplishments
as president he outlined a bold contrast
with what the Biden administration had
done and how it's performed in terms of
inflation crime the Border energy
Independence foreign policy and compared
it to where things were when he was
president it was also about as you said
what he didn't say no talk about stolen
elections or 2020. he didn't attack or
insult any of his potential opponents in
the Republican primary whether that be
Governor Grant DeSantis Florida Governor
Glenn Younkin Virginia that is smart so
this felt more like an address to the
Joint session of Congress it sounded
presidential and I think it probably
surprised more than a few folks that he
went about it this way if he continues
to do do this and sticks to the issues
it's going to be in a very interesting
primary and general election 721 days
away Sean I looked it up before we came
on until election day 2024. you know Leo
if Donald Trump I would argue his
wheelhouse is when he is talking about
the Forgotten men and women in this
country and the Forgotten men and women
in this country have suffered under
under the Biden new green deal socialist
agenda and that is the message frankly
that the entire Republican party needs
to take I'm going to go back to the
speech though hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else